foreign
[Music]
daily cancellation we turn to a sadly
familiar Story one that has played out
an almost identical fashion uh countless
times on college campuses across the
country this time it's the College of
New Jersey
daily white reports on the story of a
male college student who was
investigated by the school for sexual
assault
three years after a sexual encounter
that he says was entirely consensual
reading now it says the male student
Whom The Daily wire will call John Doe
was a freshman at TCNJ in the fall of
2017 throughout the school year a female
student referred to in court documents
as Jane Rowe regularly came over to
John's dorm to spend time with his
roommate her ex-boyfriend with whom she
was still friends
according to the lawsuit John filed
after uh TCNJ punished him
you didn't interact with Jane outside of
her visits to his dorm room on September
30th 2017 not long into his freshman
year John Jane and John's roommate were
all hanging out together in John's dorm
room at some point John's roommate left
for the night and John and Jane remained
Alone Together to continue talking into
the night which Sean says turned into
consensual kissing that lasted for a few
minutes John asked Jane to to perform
oral sex on him and she agreed after
Jane voluntarily and willingly engaged
in oral sex with John the two fell
asleep in John's bed according to the
lawsuit the next morning John asked Jane
if she wanted to have sex College
teaches students that they must ask
first to engage in any kind of sexual
activity Jane agreed and the two engaged
in what John described as conceptual
sexual intercourse uh afterward Jane
left John's dorm room and from there you
know we're told that John and Jane
maintained a friendly relationship as
acquaintances acquaintances they made
small talk when they saw each other on
campus they even apparently worked on a
calculus assignment together I have no
idea how you work on a calculus how do
you do calculus with someone I don't
know I don't know how to do calculus at
all so it's a mystery to me but in any
case everything seemed fine
everything seemed normal according to
John until a month later when Jane
started dating a different guy at the
school and this is when Jane first
started telling the story of the alleged
sexual assault uh that she supposedly
suffered at the hands of John it's
nearly another year that passes
um and then finally after another year
Jane reports this alleged crime to the
school's Title IX Department
John himself was never told apparently
about the complaint and he was never
questioned he would never get a chance
to tell a side of the story he didn't
even know about it
um and then a few weeks after opening
the case Jane told the Title IX
Department that she wanted to close it
that's back to the Daily wire report
but three years later now almost four
years since the encounter Jane asked the
Title IX office to reopen her case on
May 4th 2021 Jane filed a formal
complaint against John which required
the school to notify him of the
allegations the complaint alleged that
Jon sexually assaulted Jane and made
sexually harassing comments to her
during the Calculus class uh in the
second trim second semester rather of
their
um freshman year John was informed that
an alternative resolution agreement ARA
was being sought without telling him the
implications of such an agreement John
obtained legal counsel and was sent the
ARA which required him to perform 90
hours of community service and take
online classes John declined to accept
ARA saying that he felt it was an
unreasonable punishment for something he
didn't do according to the lawsuit since
John didn't accept ARA John Jane told
the Title IX office that she wanted to
pursue the formal resolution process
which required a hearing at this point
however John had already graduated from
TCNJ and left campus yet the school
pursued the process anyway
so now the case was fully in the hands
of the school's Kangaroo Court where all
of the the normal constitutional rights
and protections like due process which
are also you know going out the window
everywhere else too but all of that
doesn't apply
more from the report it says John's
legal counsel at the time
or at least they they act as though it
doesn't apply I should say
John's legal counsel time advised him
not to speak during the grievance
process because anything he said could
be used against him if Jane decided to
file criminal charges even though tcnj's
policies say the burden of proof is on
the school and not the accused the
school reportedly only pursued evidence
that pointed to John's guilt the school
spoke to Jane's boyfriend and her friend
who gave inconsistent statements the
school also allowed what John describes
as prejudicial hearsay statements to be
presented to the administrators
overseeing the hearing and while the
school allowed James to submit hearsay
statements regarding her mental state
John was not allowed to rebut her
statements or present evidence of his
own mental state John's Council at the
time also advised him not to attend the
hearing on November 5th 2021 he was
informed that he had been found
responsible would be suspended for two
years even though he didn't go to school
anymore and uh a note would appear on
his school transcript saying that he was
found responsible for sexual assault
so we're told that John obtained new
counsel and tried to get a new hearing
but he was denied and finally John filed
a lawsuit against the school as it
stands right now School tried to get the
lawsuit dismissed uh but that that
motion uh was was itself dismissed or
was denied
it's not certain where this goes from
here but
at least the case is in you know a real
Court
where a guy in John's situation is still
in a has a huge built-in disadvantage
it's just a slightly less huge built-in
disadvantage you know you've heard me
talk about how important it is to have a
VPN to protect your online privacy but
choosing a VPN that you trust is equally
as important I like to do research on my
sponsors I only recommend brands that I
believe in and that I will use myself so
uh to actually stop people from
monitoring your online activity you need
to do what I do and use expressvpn think
about all the times you've used Wi-Fi at
a college at a coffee shop a hotel even
at a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network and even if
you're using incognito mode it's not
really Incognito because the same thing
applies even there expressvpn is the way
to get around expressvpn as an app that
encrypts all of your network data and
reroutes it through a network of secure
servers that you're private to keep your
private online activity private
expressvpn works on all devices it's
super easy to use the app has one button
you tap the button you're connected and
it's as simple as that your browsing
activity is secure stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show use my
Link at expressvpn.com to get three
extra months free that's expressvpn
.com Matt Walsh show now here's the
point about all this two points actually
first
we don't know what really happened
between the people that we're calling
John and Jane we we do know that Jane
acted every step of the way like someone
who was not actually assaulted she
waited a month to tell anybody about the
alleged incident a year to file a
complaint then she dropped it then she
reopened it three years later
it doesn't seem likely that a real
victim would handle it this way and
regardless three years is just it's far
too late
to prove anything about an encounter
that occurred in a dorm room between two
people with no Witnesses
I mean no matter what actually happened
how could either of them possibly prove
anything one way or another three years
after the fact
of course in a legitimate legal setting
only the accuser has to prove something
so it's not what can either of them
prove there's only one person has to
prove anything that's the way it works
one of the most fundamental principles
of our legal system is that the accused
no matter the crime doesn't have to
prove his innocence
but these Title IX University tribunals
they don't recognize these uh principles
and they don't respect these basic human
rights a student
even a former student in this case is
presumed guilty of sexual assault the
moment he's accused of it
and and if he cannot come up with
overwhelming evidence that he didn't do
what he's accused of doing three years
ago in private in a room with the door
shut nobody else present
if you can't prove that which I don't
know how you possibly could then he'll
be branded a rapist
so the whole thing is uh I mean the
whole process that these universities go
through is a total farce it's exactly
why schools should not be in a position
of adjudicating these cases in the first
place if a crime was allegedly committed
it should be handled by the criminal
court system okay if a student if a
student is actually sexually assaulted
which obviously does happen then she's a
victim of a crime not merely a Title IX
infringement and she should go to the
police not the University Title IX
Department
second
if John was falsely accused
then then if he's falsely accused then
he's the real victim
and so I don't mean to victim blame when
I say this but it needs to be said this
is yet another reason
why casual sex is a very bad idea okay
according to his version of events which
to me seems the more credible version
he had oral sex and then intercourse
with a girl who
could barely be described as an
acquaintance
and she regretted according to his
account you know we can assume she
regretted the consensual counter later
and used it against him to try and ruin
his life
um there's not much he can do now to
fully clear his name especially when
he's in the hands of of the University
kangaroo courts
but the next potential false accusation
victim can do much to keep his life and
reputation intact by not having casual
sex with strangers not that's not 100
foolproof guarantee you could still be
chooses something even if you were never
in the same room as somebody anyone
could accuse anyone of anything
but you certainly are putting yourself
in a much stronger position
you know it turns out there's a reason
why those prudish social conservatives
have always recommended that sex be
saved for the bonds of marriage and this
is one of those reasons sex is obviously
the most intimate and uh personal
physical interaction that you can have
with another human being if you engage
in this act with someone you don't know
someone you have no tie to no commitment
to someone you've made no promise or
vows to you have put yourself in an
incredibly vulnerable situation in many
ways this is true for the man and the
woman equally a woman who casually
engages in the reproductive act with
some random dude
could find that the ACT had exactly the
reproductive result that it is designed
to have
and now she's in the position of
carrying a child whose father she barely
knows
a man for his part could easily find
himself in the position that John is in
now if the woman decides
that she regrets the encounter
and if she has no Integrity then she
could make a false claim against him but
of course the man has no idea whether
she's this sort of woman whether she has
Integrity or not because he doesn't know
her and yet had sex with her anyway
um even if there are no false
accusations and no pregnancies and no
other consequences of that sort still
both people involved will be left with
the emotional and spiritual damage of
having given themselves physically to a
stranger they allowed themselves to be
used as an object and this I believe is
where many of the false accusations come
from
in cases of false accusations in many
cases I think
you know the woman wakes up the next
morning feels used you know
um and and she was used except that it
was it was consensual and it was Mutual
she used the man as much as he used her
that's what all casual sex is that's
what hookup culture is they were both
dehumanized and they were both
diminished by the encounter but they
participated in it if it was consensual
um
they weren't assaulted they aren't
victims
but they were harmed both of them
in ways that may or may not they they
may or may not come to understand
you know it turns out that you can
engage in something consensually and it
can still harm you it could still be bad
so this can all be avoided by simply
putting the horse in front of the cart
instead of the other way around okay
um
you know this is meant to be sex is
meant to be an expression of love
between a man and a woman who actually
love each other and are devoted and
committed to each other so
take care of the devotion and commitment
first
and then you get to the the sex and and
then you don't have to worry about
this stuff anymore
and that is why in the end after all
this it is hookup culture that we must
once again
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]